this program is brought to you by Emory
University
it's it's unusual that when there's a
problem which is such a huge problem
that there are actually people who are
alive who were there in the beginning
and and that's true for many of the
people in this room as well as well as
me and it really makes me grateful of
being in Atlanta and seeing what's
happened that gradient at Emory over
time in terms of research and care for
people with HIV if speaking with
Angelica before the meeting an Angelica
when I first met her was a very very
young woman working and she worked at at
Grady Memorial Hospital taking care of
patients in a very small crowded
uncomfortable place but was committed to
caring for people at a time when aids
was shunned it's always been a
discrimination and fear has always been
a real problem with AIDS but in the
early days you know there were stories
that people leaving trays out in the
hallway for patients who were cared for
even here in Atlanta people being afraid
to take care of HIV patients because
they themselves might be infected and it
was the vision of Angelica her
colleagues a very close friend and
colleague of mine Sam Thompson which led
to eventually the purchase I guess 18
years ago of the old Methodist Center
Presbyterian Senate press but yet the
wrong Church the old Presbyterian Center
which is made into the pasta lien clinic
which is a clinic that is well known
throughout the world for being at the
forefront of HIV care and HIV research I
think we can be really proud that this
clinic was involved in the very
beginning and the clinical trials
efforts and that it more than ever now
is at the forefront of HIV clinical
trials both for treatment and prevention
not only does that lead to the best care
and attract the best providers but it
also makes sure that
the patients who come here have access
to the very latest information and very
latest care the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University